trg de cette journée dans l'actualité
l'enseignement catholique ne peut
négocier sur les bases proposées par
alain savary
le ministre de l'éducation les seuls
points de départ pour une négociation
reste pour le comité national le
maintien d'établissement d'initiatives
privées associées au grand service
public d'éducation et surtout des
garanties explicites préalable à
d'éventuelles négociations comme
l'autonomie juridique financière
administrative des établissements la
liberté de choix pour les familles leur
formation dans un cadre contractuel la
liberté des communautés éducatives de
s'associer et de s'organiser entre aide
pour la poursuite d'objectifs comme
voilà donc la position de l'enseignement
catholique werlen frédéric pour
commencer ce débat face à l'indépendance
terre de l'express d'un frédéric vous
êtes journaliste à l'humanité
quelle est votre réaction est ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'il y à un
refus de négociations de la part de
recevant catholique bien je crois que
c'est un refus négociations et je trouve
que c'est pour le moins regrettable
lente et lens terre votre réaction dans
cette position je ne pense pas que ce
soit un refus de principe de
négociations je pense que c'est un refus
des bases qui ont été proposés pour
cette négociation et qu'il y a de la
part de l'enseignement catholique des
contre propositions positives alors plus
concrètement quelles sont d'après vous
les contributions positives susceptibles
d'être accepté par monsieur c varie bien
la liberté de choix géographique de
l'établissement d'enseignement par les
parents qui semble aux parents au moins
jusqu'à maintenant une liberté
élémentaire ils n'ont pas envie
évidemment qu'on leur retire mais elle
est menacée cette liberté de choix
elle est menacée dans ce qu'on appelle
la carte scolaire qui obligerait les
parents selon le lieu d'habitation à
mettre les enfants dans une école de
tels secteurs et n'ont pas de tel autre
ces votes ravir les menaces et cette
liberté que j'écoute est sur le point de
détail de la carte scolaire
je pense qu'elle n'est pas menacée je
pense que les mesures proposées par le
ministre alain savary vous même dans le
sens d'un plus grand choix aux parents
puisque non seulement ils pourront
choisir entre divers établissements
privés anciennement privé entre ces
établissements d'intérêt public mais
encore ils pourront choisir entre des
établissements publics c'est une
nouveauté puisque jusqu'à maintenant
il n'avait pas ce choix là mais je crois
que sur ce problème
enseignement privé enseignement public
c'est un peu paradoxal mais je crois que
la question essentielle n'est pas public
privé la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui je crois qu'ils se posent à
l'ensemble des parents qui soient des
parents catholiques ou non catholiques
qu'ils aient leurs enfants à l'école
privée ou qu'ils aient des enfants
l'école publique c'est celui de la
réussite des enfants c'est celui de la
de l'échec scolaire il ya
malheureusement énormément d'enfants qui
sont en situation d'échec à l'école 1
16% cours préparatoire et notre 48% au
cours moyen 2e année c'est à dire à
l'entrée en sixième et ça se poursuit
il ya le problème de l'inégalité sociale
ya problème de la sélection sociale vous
savez très bien qu'en france
malheureusement qui vont dans les écoles
privées il n'y a pas que les enfants de
riches qui vont dans les écoles privées
mais que ce soit dans l'enseignement
privé où que ce soit dans l'enseignement
public
si vous êtes fils d'un os par exemple
malheureusement vous avez très peu de
chance de rentrer au lycée et qui plus
est à l'université il ya quand même un
choix dès le départ que ce soit
l'enseignement privé que ce soit
l'enseignement public il n'y a pas de
meilleure réussite dans l'enseignement
privé
donc il ya un problème de rénovation
d'enseignement et c'est dans ce cadre là
que le ministre a fait ces propositions
concernant l'enseignement privé
je crois que c'est ça l'important c'est
la rénovation du système éducatif
français
alors les dirigeants de l'enseignement
catholique sont tout à fait partisan du
principe d'une rénovation du système
éducatif français
d'autant plus que et sur ce point je
suis en accord avec vous l'enseignement
public ne suffit pas à tous les besoins
il a besoin du privé est naturellement
le privé ne pourrait pas être seul en
france
donc nous nous trouvons devant deux
formes d'enseignement qui sont
complémentaires l'une de l'autre
mais alors que vous avez tout à fait
raison ce qui concerne les chances de
l'enfant de l'ol et que vous montrer les
différences de chance selon le milieu
social il ne faudrait pas charger
financièrement les établissements privés
parce que sinon alors on en ferait pour
le coup des écoles du riche qui serait
réservée aux élèves dont les parents
auraient une certaine fortune
et puis les autres enfants perdrait
les chances qu'ils ont est actuellement
c'est ce que vous redoutez vous pensez
que la réforme proposée par monsieur
savary charge financièrement les
établissements privés je crois qu'il y
aura de toute façon du privé qui
subsistera en france qu'ils soient
confessionnelle ou non et je crains que
ce privé s'il y a une charge financière
plus forte soit réservé simplement aux
enfants les plus riches
écoutez le problème il y pas de savoir
si des établissements privés doivent
subsister je crois comme vous qui dans
subsistera toujours mais je crois que
pour l'essentiel il ya un problème de
justice il ya un problème en public
privé il ya depuis 1959 avec la loi
debré ensuite avec les lois guermeur
l'état et les communes ont été mis à
contribution et finance des
établissements privés les finances sans
contrepartie
on n'a jamais vu ça imaginez un peu
qu'il y ait en france des écoles
appartenant à des syndicats d'autres
associations voire des partis politiques
qu'ils soient financés par l'état tout
le monde protesteraient et une serait
raison on aurait raison de protester
contre ce genre de financement
d'associations là si on parle d'école
privée et on veut je m'amuse quand la
danoise mois public
bon alors je ne suis pas d'accord
continuer mais je vais vous dire quoi
écouter avant je crois que justement il
y avait il y avait beaucoup de
possibilités il y avait la possibilité
du statu quo mais ce n'est pas juste il
y avait la possibilité de nationaliser
purement et simplement l'enseignement
privé
ce n'est pas la voie qui a été choisie
par le gouvernement est en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne les communistes pour qui
ce qui concerne mon parti nous n'avons
jamais proposé la nationalisation
brutale de l'enseignement privé bien au
contraire nous avons proposé qui me
annie spoliation
ni
ni nationalisation brutal mais qu'on
discute qu'on dialogue pour résoudre un
problème posé à tout un chacun parce que
tout le monde paye des impôts
il n'est pas normal de financer à la
fois des établissements prévus public et
des établissement privé je crois pour en
revenir à ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure il ya un problème de rénovation
enseignement ce problème de rénovation
de l'enseignement ne pourra être
solutionnée que qu'en mobilisant toutes
les ressources actuellement disponibles
en france dans les accroissant il faut
parler aussi du budget on devrait donner
un peu plus à l'éducation nationale mais
en mobilisant déjà les ressources dont
dispose la nation du point de vue
d'enseignement et il faut mobiliser les
ressources de l'enseignement public qui
sont à certains assez importante et les
ressources de l'enseignement privé qui
ne sont pas négligeables
et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à exprimer
un point de désaccord on l'aimerait
peut-être entendre son point d accord
oui je dis que lorsqu'il ya financement
d'une école privée
il y a une contrepartie qui est
l'enseignement qui est l'éducation qui
est donnée par cette école privée jeudi
que lorsqu'il y a de l'argent des
parents qui est dépensé
ça devrait aller à l'école que
souhaitent ses parents et oui vous je
m'étonne que au moment où nous nous
trouvons devant une grande revendication
de droit à la différence
à laquelle la nouvelle majorité a donné
satisfaction sous forme de la
régionalisation sous forme des radios
locales
voilà un pluralisme le pluralisme
scolaire quand vous êtes au contraire
faire disparaître sous une forme
d'intégration général j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une liberté qui est menacée au
moment où précisément en accorde des
libertés dans d'autres domaines
juste juste sur cette question justement
je crois pas que la liberté de
conscience et la liberté religieuse soit
menacée en france je crois pas que
l'enseignement public services publics
ne puissent pas garantir cette liberté
de conscience
j'aimerais qui la garantissent mieux
parce que si à l'heure actuelle il y a
une liberté de conscience une dimension
qui n'est pas retenu les compris qui
n'est pas retenue dans l'enseignement
je crois plutôt que c'est un peu sont un
peu nos idées des idées communistes les
idées marxistes
donc je crois que s'il ya quelqu'un qui
peut revendiquer le pluralisme dans
l'enseignement c'est bien nous et nous
ne nous en privons pas mais je crois pas
que ce soit un problème de liberté de
conscience vous savez toutes les
statistiques sauf dans certaines régions
de france bien délimitées
toutes les statistiques ont montré que
les parents ne mettait pas leurs enfants
dans les écoles privées pour des raisons
idéologiques pour des raisons
religieuses mais parce qu'ils doutent de
la réussite du service public il faut
leur montrer
il faut relever le défi il faut leur
montrer que le service public est
capable de leur donner un enseignement
de qualité et un enseignement pluraliste
bien mais je pense aussi qu'il faut un
pluralisme dans le choix que les
familles puissent choisir un type
d'éducation et qu'il y ait entre ces
types d'éducation une coexistence
pacifique
je ne pense pas qu'il faille devant les
difficultés qu'ont les jeunes
actuellement ressusciter un débat
héritées du passé
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
et puisque vous parlez de coexistence
pacifique et bien il fallait prendre la
balle au bond le ministre le 23 décembre
rappelait qu'il a fait des propositions
mais qu'on peut en faire d'autres
et que c'est ça une négociation il
suffisait à l'enseignement catholique
d'aller dans ce sens là de faire des
propositions des propositions balade des
propositions dont on peut discuter
il fait des contre-propositions positive
simplement ce qu'on lui a proposé ne lui
semble pas pour le moment acceptable
écoutez une réforme de l'enseignement
oui mais si la question posée revient à
à quelle sauce désirez vous être mangés
pour le moment et dit non il est pas
question de manger qui que ce soit je
crois qu'il est question positivement de
rénover le système éducatif français je
crois qu'il a besoin de toutes les
énergies pour ça soit on joue ce débat
est maintenant terminée après dix
minutes
nous allons parler maintenant de la
météo les températures ne sont pas trop
fraîche en france aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'il en sera de même pour
demain les prévisions dallas gillot
pétré
restez chez vous cette nuit ou allumer
vos antibrouillards ces derniers seront
généralisés cette nuit et localement
givrants de l'aquitaine au morvan la
mi-journée venu il fera beau sur la
moitié sud du pays
mais nuageux sur la moitié nord avec de
petites bruines de la manche au nord-est
températures froides tendance au
réchauffement merci à la voilà pour ce
journal un peu nouvelle formule avec un
débat nous essaierons de faire ce que tu
es débat ait lieu pratiquement tous les
soirs pendant une dizaine de minutes
enfin de confronter des idées sur un
fait d'actualité merci alain penasse
terre merci bien leur frédéric d'avoir
bien voulu inaugurer cette formule pour
soir à demain merci